I thought if he thought the way he
always fights that would be a car Raisie
fight.
But he was so nervous from that fight
from the steep bay fight that he just did
terrible. He just couldn't pull the
trigger. They're frozen of hurt back.
So you've got a complete shit
show out of two knockout artists.
I just think that um, that uh, you know,
has been out for a long time. He's a
motherfucker though. He's the best.
I think he the best. I think he's the
best in terms of like physical ability.
You think he's the best heavyweight
of all time? I think he's the best.
I think he has to do,
I used to do a little more work.
Think he's the best in terms
of what he's accomplished.
I think fate or is the best heavyweight
of all time in terms of what he's
accomplished.
Maybe maybe you can make the argument for,
for BC over doom because
we're doing beat him,
but I think for doing beat a fade or
that had already been through the ringer
and pride and all the chaos over there.
I mean he had been in those
wars with fucking cro cop,
but for doing beat him when it was still
the ORIF fade or he was the first one
where,
where you realized she was shooting of,
cause Brett Rogers kind of
took a little bit out of that.
Did he starched fucking payout them but
before that he had trouble with them.
It was a, it wasn't an easy
fight. It wasn't an easy
fight. It was me. Respect Brat.
Right.
He did have a cro cop like,
I mean you'll curl hop fucking
punch and leaped and Oh fucking God.
You know with that right hand and right
hand was redonkulous though I it's, it's,
it's tough to say greatest of all time
because it's the greatest of that time
period because when,
when he was doing it,
there were specialists that he was great.
There were certain things
that made him great.
He was under size because if you put his
skill set with his frame now into the,
the, the pool, it's, I
don't know if he's the best,
but then Cain at his time when there's
jds and he's in his prime Brock Lesnar
and he's beating those guys,
what cane would do to people,
he would overwhelm you in a way
that looked like you were drowning.
His Cardio and pace was
insane. Insane. Like did you,
did junior dos Santos fights I think
took so much out of junior, both of them.
I think it took it, both of them paid the
price. Yeah. It was the same thing as a,
I was listened to.
Um,
who's the box you just had on from a
love Kelly Pavlik how you were saying he
doesn't watch the rematch with Canelo
triple g cause it takes so much out of
those guys that they're never the same.
I'm using,
I'm usually on the same thinking
path. Is that where I'm like, God,
if those guys go out again,
man, we're never going to
get a good product. But Cain,
Cain and junior for sure.
I mean,
especially the third fight and the third
fight was second one to the second one
to pop both of them. They just then
jds a steep bay. Yeah, that was,
that was quite steep.
And jds has had some Warthen steep.
It has had some wars and you can,
you can tell that they're there.
They're just different in life. I'm not
saying it's brain train, whatever it is,
but it's just, they're just
different. They're not,
they leave a piece of themselves in that,
in that octagon.
Well it's for sure some brain trauma.
Yeah.
I'm just trying to be nice to try and
be nice and getting hit in the head that
much. Like they, they, they leave,
they leave a little piece of mint
in there for our entertainment.
And I feel a little guilty about what's
crazy. This was no talk about Steve Bay.
Steve paid the most accomplished
heavyweight of all time.
He's the greatest in terms
of like his accomplishments.
He defended the title more than anybody.
He didn't fight the best guys in their
prime when he fought junior and junior
was definitely past his
prime knock on him. Right.
But again, when, when it
was his run during his era,
Steve Bay's the best when
it was Kane during his era,
he was the best fade or was the best.
It's hard to say this has been in this
guy because it's just a different time
period. Right. Jordan better than Lebron
Jordan during that era. By far the best,
the Brown right now, by far the best.
It's stupid. We don't know. I don't know.
You know, so that's, that's the
question about steep pace. Like why,
why is there no talk
about him fighting again?
Like why have they not said
something he's trying, he's trying.
Like he even tweeted that he
goes DC before your retire.
Let's do it, man. Yeah.
Like quit waiting for
John. Let's do it. Well,
he's being really active
on social media trying to,
but it doesn't seem like there's
a lot cause he has to be,
because you know why it's not in his
nature. We know that's not steepened.
We know that. That's not Steve. He's a
firefighter. Humble, blue collar dude.
He's going to put in work.
Comes to fight all the time.
So Derrick Lewis explains
turning down Steve Bay fight.
Derrick says they wanted me to
fight steep at short notice.
I wanted some time off. I would still
fight steep pay, but not right now.
Not so soon.
Especially after you're fighting a guy
like DC who's more of a wrestler thing,
going to fight steep pay.
I know I wanted some time off.
So they tried getting steep a fight, so
they were trying to get them for the UFC.
He's a Brooklyn car this weekend.
Nuts. Uh, was that this weekend,
but it's smart of Derek Lewis.
They see when you go DC then Steve Bay,
there couldn't be two
worst match ups for him.
He's going to get paid to beatings.
You're going to take, but you know,
it's likely unless he connects.
Yeah.